hello reject nation greg alba here john
this got sent to us and it sound like a
lot of fly solo a Star Wars story
trailer recode the sabotage dog it's
gonna feel like the Star Trek trailer
yeah patron deja for Jay and Valente
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta cool
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that worked that worked better that
makes you that that they they had those
two directors again that actually worked
better I think you don't get a hearing
audio because he couldn't just take
audio from it cousin music playing but
in some ways I thought that actually
didn't complement it better it didn't of
course remind me of the Star Trek
trailer because of the fat and sabotage
just using that Star Trek 1 and 2 star
trek into darkness one not darkness no
beyond the on Star Trek beyond into the
darkness of the Star Trek yeah I'm kind
of hoping the movie has I don't know I
mean I guess the sabotage song works
because oh yeah I mean it just seems
like sabotaging this movie because you
know of all the director switches and
they're still releasing it in May hey
man this song over this trailer made me
think it I don't know it looked like a
good time it made it look like a more
fun time in ho and you know it's not
gonna have that tone I don't know I feel
like a han Solo maybe should be a
certain degree of fun no no no no it
should be serious yeah Hans most serious
Han yeah he's a protocol guy yeah no
time for don't get cocky kid that's
funny but in a serious way that's not
how the force works
exasperated yeah it's funny but in a
dark way I don't know hey guys listen
here's what I got to say about solo
though everyone's like this is not
necessary doing a back story on him can
ruin the character not getting Harrison
Ford can ruin it I disagree with all
that this is very with all that I
usually what it should have been from
the 7d for the start I feel like they
should have started with a han Solo
movie then giving us a Star Wars yeah
that's really the point think of how
much is missing from the Star Wars
universe up until this point that we
haven't gotten because this wasn't made
I hate Han and I think that if we get to
know his backstory I might appreciate
more of who Han is and in general I just
hate Harrison Ford and matter of fact I
hate Star Wars this could fix it no
respect for
everything no respect I mean it sack of
the Clones is alright yeah
Phantom Menace yeah all the ones without
Han have been a great yeah n64 game were
you the podrace I know it only got like
99% audience rating approval the last
Jedi but I think this will you get it to
a solid 100 I think this is what the
franchise you guys see red letter media
is terrific reaction
you guys go watch red letter media is
trailer reaction on this because what
they did was they first did reaction
without having seen the trailer and all
the things that will be in the trailer
but they are watching it and then they
reloaded that same video a few days
later hey Jam Valente and wanted to give
you a shout out here because you're like
a solo patron you are barely get back to
us and when you do it's like a giant
message from yeah yeah it feels like
you've like gone off the grid traveled
the world seen many things then you come
back with these nuggets for us yeah all
compounded into this scientist novel
assemble than a message for us which we
appreciate when we get to hear from you
but then hardened please so intermittent
it's like Keira you it's like we have a
whole patron community and there's a you
it's like solo a real region you're out
across the galaxy man you're trying to
sabotage your relationship with us buddy
is that what's going on huh hey hey hey
we love him and he knows I hope you know
and one shot first no he did okay
whatever
hey but Jan listen dude I'm glad you're
still here and you're such a great
supporter of the channel buddy I hope
that you can get back to us more
frequently we would try to get a Google
hangout going with you for like 6 months
now I don't feel like you care to talk
with us I wonder why that is
I feel like we've talked about with him
yeah on your terms brother whatever
whatever is good subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell JN
I hope to hear from you soon buddy
because I feel like I know so much about
you and I feel like I know nothing about
you at the same time yeah you're you're
another international man of mystery